voilà vous jouez le rôle d'une
institutrice dans le film c'est un peu
plus strictes solex et c'est le but
d'une actrice et passer d'un univers à
un autre
moi j'ai accepté le projet en fait parce
que j'ai la famille pieds noirs
il ya au sein de la famille des gens qui
qui on perd la différence encore et je
voulais c'est une façon d'être engagé
dans un projet comme ça c'est une façon
de dire aussi ya pas de bons n'y a pas
de mauvais dans cette histoire il ya
juste beaucoup de beaucoup d'ignorance
beaucoup de peur beaucoup
d'incompréhension de part et d'autre
donc c'était une façon pour moi aussi de
régler des choses alors je vais le rôle
d'une institutrice donc qui révoltée par
le comportement de la police française
qui est surtout très naïve aucune idée
de ce qui se passe genre d'endroit et
elle a un coup de coeur pour ce jeune
homme et en l'accompagnant elle découvre
le le comportement inacceptable alors si
l'histoire qui est toujours absente des
livres d'histoire justement quand le
livre de hainaut 10 est paru la bataille
de paris
papon attaqué et il a fallu attendre
delanoë en 2001 pour qu'une plaque
commémorative soit placé sur le pont
saint-michel voilà tu connais cette
histoire d'un mois ouais je la connais
ils balançaient des saucissons comme ça
schieber tête pour faire évacuer tous
les arabes et pour qui les faire reculer
ouais mon père m'a raconté
effrayant un effrayant et totalement
comment dire occultée pendant des
décennies